the ACT your wage Trend which has taken  off on Tick Tock is apparently best  explained by this viral video  okay Veronica I'm gonna need you to  complete  complete Susan do I look like two people  to you no oh okay just making sure  because that looks like the work of two  people right right and I'm one I'm just  one person right  and it's time to go home five o'clock  hey thank you bye you cannot talk to  your boss that way you might you might  wish that you could but you can't so in  the real world where your boss comes up  to you no I'm not doing that Susan get  the hell out of here this is not a movie  you can't talk to people that way it's a  good way to get yourself fired in the  real world